what you will see
is an accumulation of facts and
disturbing patterns of behavior colin
powell predicted this address to the un
would be a prominent paragraph in his
obituary iraq's behavior demonstrates
that sodom hussein and his regime have
made no effort no effort
to disarm as required by the
international community he will be
remembered as the man who put forward
the case to invade iraq citing faulty
intelligence of weapons of mass
destruction a blot on his career he said
which haunted him
but it is just part of his legacy
shaping american foreign policy for
decades and blazing a trail for black
people in the military and politics i
lost
a
tremendous personal friend and mentor
he has been my mentor for a number of
years
he always made time for me
and i could always go to him with tough
issues he always had great
great counsel
we will certainly miss him i feel as if
i have a hole in my heart
powell was the son of jamaican
immigrants when he began his military
career he was forbidden from entering
certain restaurants in georgia a state
clinging on to segregation
he rose to become the first black man to
chair the joint chiefs of staff under
george bush senior and under his son
george bush jr he was appointed the
first black secretary of state
in a statement bush wrote he was such a
favorite of presidents that he earned
the presidential medal of freedom twice
he was highly respected at home and
abroad and most important colin was a
family man and a friend
over four decades in public life powell
stood shoulder to shoulder with british
leaders from margaret thatcher to tony
blair he considered running for the
presidency himself in 1996 but wife alma
worried for his safety
powell was a republican but in recent
years distanced himself from the party
supporting barack obama's presidential
campaign and later denouncing former
president trump
across washington flags were lowered
today across the political aisle they
mourned the most devoted of public
servants martha kellner sky news
washington